dans votre livre vous dites que tout le
monde doit se sentir concerné par le
sujet pourquoi
parce que si vous voulez c'est pas c'est
pas seulement le fait qu'il y a des gens
qui décident de même à un moment donné
de ce d'acheter la drogue et voilà et de
la consommer pour eux-mêmes ça c'est ça
peut ça peut avoir ça peut avoir un
impact éventuellement sur le sur leur
santé mais après je pense que le marché
de la drogue a bouleversent on va dire
le pacte social d'une certaine manière
ça fausse le rapport à l'argent puisque
on a d'un côté des gens qui se sont
mettent plein les poches extrêmement
rapidement sans payer d'impôts etc ça
fausse ça fausse le rapport ça corrompt
la drogue coron également il y a
énormément de d'or comment
énormément de regardez pas il y a
énormément de voilà et il y a tellement
d'argent si vous voulez derrière que ça
corrompre donc ça ça là aussi ça se
trouve le facteur social et le petit
gamin qui meurt puisque voilà ça oui non
c'est pas ça c'est intéressant ça
trouble pardon excusez-moi je dirais
qu'on disait des trucs intéressants de
petites minutes non mais donc ça trouble
effectivement l'ordre social quand vous
avez des gamins qui qui paraladent au
pied d'une tour dans un quartier sur de
magnifiques de motos voitures etc vous
savez très bien que la que les que les
gens qui habitent le quartier sont à la
fenêtre détestent cela et il y a un
moment donné il y a il y a une on va
dire ça crée ça crée un véritable
malaise parce que ça veut dire ça
en contact au moins une fois avec un
arcotrafiquant
moi surtout parce que effectivement je
l'ai cherché
voilà c'est l'idée c'est là aussi où je
voudrais dire que ça ça nous concerne
c'est que quelque part c'est tout cet
argent les trafiquants de drogue ils ont
un problème c'est d'importer jusque
aux narines des consommateurs leurs
produits qui qui évolue mieux donc là il
faut affrêter des avions des bateaux etc
c'est dans ce sens là mais après ils ont
un autre problème qu'on imagine pas
c'est qu'il faut traiter les montagnes
de billets de banque que ça représente
parce que ça représente des montagnes
des caves moi en France le marché de la
drogue représente 4 milliards d'euros
par an c'est le chiffre auquel je suis
arrivé à priori c'est a priori
aujourd'hui on est en Europe 24 à 50
milliards dans le monde 650 milliards de
dollars ça fait un tour sur l'Europe
pardon la France
c'est l'idée en terme de consommation
mais ça fait en gros 1 % du PIB français
c'est le marché d'avoir le nom c'est 4
milliards il faut bien qu'ils aillent
quelque part et là où ça trouble aussi
là où ça aussi un impact sur la société
c'est que précisément il y a des gens
qui arrivent et qui achètent des
magasins des pas de porte ça peut être
ça peut être petit ça peut être des
ongleries ça peut être des sandwichs ça
peut être des kebabs des choses comme ça
avec de l'argent sale donc à partir de
là si vous êtes un commerçant normal
ordinaire vous êtes forcément défavorisé
et sa déséquilibre le rapport les
rapports sociaux pour cette raison là
parce que dans 4 milliards d'euros par
an en petits coupures c'est compliqué
j'ai calculé les Français rien que si on
rien que concernant le si on parle du
cannabis les Français roulent à peu près
une tonne de cannabis en juin par jour
une tonne c'est pas une tonne une tonne
et demi de cannabis sont roulés chaque
jour France pardon ça fait ça fait 30 30
plus de 30 tonnes par mois de consommer
oui c'est c'est quand même énorme et
vous dit ça génère des billets de banque
c'est de l'argent pardon vous dites que
la drogue c'est un des rares secteurs
qui connaît pas du tout la crise vous
parlez de marche avec 15000 % pour
certains narcotrafiquants c'est du
jamais vu alors effectivement en terme
de marge et de progression les
producteurs par exemple concernant la
cocaïne les producteurs qui sont en
Colombie en Équateur ou en Bolivie on
multiplier par deux leur production en
disant donc il y a énormément de
marchandises sur le marché donc du côté
de l'offre il y a aucun souci après du
côté de la demande il ne cesse d'en
créer davantage et ce qu'on moi ce que
j'observe sur les cinq six dernières
années sur le marché de la drogue en
France c'est que en gros la drogue a
quitté enfin quitté c'est propagé à
partir des grands centres urbains vers
les vers toutes les sous-préfectures et
qu'on en trouve absolument partout et la
dernière chose concernant le prix et la
crise c'est effectivement il y a un
indice fort c'est que le prix du kilo de
beurre du kilo de farine du kilo du pain
augmente mais pas le prix des produits
stupéfiant ça c'est un signe important
ça veut dire que la demande est là les
prix sont à peu près stables depuis 10
ans donc ça veut dire que même s'il y a
des saisies il y a des saisies qui
induisent des pertes importantes pour
les trafiquants enfin des pères
on nous c'est vrai que une la perte
d'une tonne en réalité à chaque fois on
dit ça fait des millions et pour ça fait
des millions mais non mais en réalité le
problème c'est que le pied de cocaïne
qui pousse quand on le ramasse dans la
montagne il coûte 2 centimes 20 centimes
pas plus que ça là en réalité la valeur
marchande elle est à partir du moment où
ils ont franchi toutes les frontières
j'entends monsieur mais une fois qu'ils
sont en France le drame est déjà fait et
c'est le pays qui consomme le plus
j'avais deux exemples et puis on sait
que maintenant il y a plus trop de
casinos donc l'argent il l'avait par
plein de choses souvent pour laver sa
bagnole tout ça c'est souvent plein de
trucs comme ça
quand je suis allé
au Brésil à Rio à l'époque ils décidé
que tous les drogues étaient dans les
favelas ils ont envoyé l'armée pas pour
chasser les gens chasser les dealers et
tout ça dans chacune des favelas l'arbée
ça s'est battu et il mettait un
commissaire et c'était gagné pourquoi
est-ce que dans toutes les banlieues
extrêmement chaudes où on sait qu'il y a
aujourd'hui les points les plus
importants on en voit pas puisqu'on ne
peut pas envoyer la police elle est pas
fait pour on en voit pas l'armée pour
nettoyer véritablement le pays parce que
Pasqua disait pour tout arrêter il faut
que les gens aient peur ils n'ont pas
peur alors il y a une différence entre
la France et le Brésil moi je suis allé
enquêter notamment en Guyane je suis
allé en Brésil voilà je suis allé au
Colombie une différence si vous voulez
c'est que par exemple la Guyane c'est un
territoire français en Amérique du Sud
sur le traitement des trafiquants et des
orpailleurs il y a deux méthodes les
Brésiliens ils arrivent
ils tirent et tout le monde non c'est
pas priori non mais c'est ce qu'il
annonce c'est la réalité c'est ce que je
vous raconte je l'ai vu mais les
Français et bon ils ont des règles des
lois c'est beaucoup plus compliqué pour
eux de fonctionner comme ça donc nous en
France ben on a on a on a la justice on
doit faire des enquêtes etc après si
vous envoyez l'armée dans ces dans ces
quartiers où les bons lézards
seraient non mais d'accord mais une fois
qu'on a mis mon nouveau dcs par exemple
là le gouvernement vient de décider
d'envoyer une compagnie de CRS en
permanence des CRS de d'édite hein et
les envoyer sur Marseille en réalité ça
rassure les gens les bonnes gens qui
sont là et qui voit tout ça se dérouler
en bas de chez eux mais ça ne ça n'a pas
de réel impact sur les trafiquants de
stupéfiants ce qui les fait tomber
malheureusement ce sont les enquêtes au
long cours de la police judiciaire on
est quand même voilà donc ce que je
suggère moi plutôt que d'envoyer l'armée
c'est de renforcer cette police
judiciaire qui aujourd'hui met un peu en
état d'affaiblissement de la renforcer
d'envoyer des gens qui qui font
réellement du du renseignement criminel
qu'on sache un peu ce qui se passe il y
a beaucoup de Français qui travaillent
sur le marché de la drogue vous dit
240000 personnes
sur la France ça représente là où il y a
il y a 20 ans il y avait deux points de
Deal il y en a 20 ou 50 aujourd'hui
c'est pas et et
[Musique]
leur terrain en état mais pour conquérir
en général celui du voisin et c'est ce
qui met un peu le le bordel mais pour
finir sur l'argent donc en bas vous avez
des vous avez des gens qui en bas à ceux
qui sont en bas de l'échelle ceux qui
sont en première ligne ce qui prennent
les balles eux ils gagnent environ 3000
€ par mois sans payer d'impôts donc
c'est déjà c'est déjà pas mal
en plus et en plus on leur livre
éventuellement à midi la canette et le
kebab ça c'est gratuit ça fait partie du
du des glorieux et c'est eux qui qui
participent on va dire au petit
blanchiment qui est celui qu'on assiste
dans toutes les banlieues du monde
touché par l'argent sale sous forme de
réinjection dans l'économie propre
c'est-à-dire les les fringues les voilà
toutes les marques là aussi vous avez
vous avez une économie mondialisée du
crime qui brasse des milliards et qui
intéresse les banques
je rappelle qu'en 2018 lors de la grande
crise économique les banques ont absorbé
plus de 2000 milliards d'argent sales
pour se rééquilibrer et il y a eu même
des procès là-dessus aux États-Unis vous
avez ce niveau-là et vous avez tout en
bas de l'échelle effectivement moi j'en
ai rencontré un jeune un jour dans en
Saint-Denis en Seine-Saint-Denis dans un
quartier il avait 16-17 ans il avait
commencé tout en bas et son rêve c'était
de prendre la place du chef évidemment
comme à chaque fois dans ces dans ces
cas-là et lui il avait déjà à 16 ans à
16 ans il avait déjà investi dans son
pays d'origine qui était pour lui le
Congo Brazzaville où il avait acheté il
avait investi dans une crêperie il avait
créé une crêperie au pays vous avez ce
niveau là et vous avez le blanchiment on
va dire d'abord il y a aussi le
blanchiment quotidien c'est vous allez
dans les magasins de luxe c'est pour ça
qu'il y a plein de 100 euros c'est pour
ça qu'on peut plus payer plus de 1000
euros c'est pour éviter à quoi ça sert
quand on a 25 ans et qu'on se crame la
vie tous les jours et qu'on sait qu'on
va mourir à 27 à quoi ça sert d'avoir
autant d'argent en gros si on peut pas
se payer une relax je dirais c'est ça
c'est c'est en gros c'est la la Rolex
est obligatoire le fait d'acheter une
petite Austin aussi à sa maîtresse
puisqu'il y a plusieurs maîtresses il
faut acheter plusieurs hostiles le fait
d'aller offrir il y a eu une vente aux
enchères il y a quelques jours de bien
saisir chez criminels dedans il y avait
notamment un pyjama Dior voilà si on
peut passer ça si on a 25 ans qu'on
risque sa vie tous les jours et qu'on
peut pas se payer le pyjama Dior et la
Rolex on a tout raté donc c'est pas
c'est pas 50 ans là c'est 25 ans là je
limite donc effectivement ça c'est du
blanchiment enfin disons c'est de la
dépense quotidienne et ensuite vous avez
le blanchiment d'ultra proximité et dans
les quartiers si vous enquêtez un peu
vous rendez compte que souvent la petite
épicerie petit salon de coiffure enfin
c'est vraiment du du bas du bas de gamme
mais c'est pas c'est pas inutile parce
que il s'achète ça et après ça ça sert
de lessiveuse c'est à dire que si vous
avez un kebab non mais que vous avez
trois clients par jour vous en avez plus
vous avez trois clients par jour et vous
allez le déclarer vous allez vous allez
en déclarer 100 donc vous avez
évidemment le kebab vu compris que ça
coûte c'est des espèces ça fait rentrer
de l'espèce à la fin vous allez
éventuellement payer des impôts sur les
100 que vous avez vendu que vous n'avez
pas vendu donc vous blanchissez c'est
c'est une manière très simple en fait
très c'est une technique assez simple
pour blanchir localement l'argent
alors oui oui là-bas il est dit que en
fait le trafic de drogue si on arrêtait
complètement les pays auraient des
problèmes économiques réels qu'en
Amérique par Miami c'est construit
uniquement sur la drogue ici
couper le flow de pognon il y avait un
risque de crise économique donc ça c'est
en fait ça arrange tout le monde ou de
laisser faire de façon si on regarde
l'histoire moi je fais beaucoup de
d'histoire du gourmandisme j'ai
travaillé sur sur Jacky
lematoires et si vous voulez si vous
regardez sur le sur le long terme
effectivement on peut se poser la
question de savoir il y a des points de
ville où vous allez où je vais comme ça
où je regarde et il me disais mais mon
grand frère faisait ça ah ben et puis
mon père faisait ça et puis et vous
rendez compte que depuis 20 ou 30 ans
effectivement il y a des endroit où on a
laissé sans quitter véritablement comme
un cancer qu'on ne voudrait pas soigner
cette cette drogue probablement parce
que ça participait d'une certaine forme
d'équilibre social et qui a un certain
nombre notamment d'élus locaux ce sont
dit on constaté qu'il valait mieux
peut-être un peu laisser faire pourquoi
pas retenir un peu la police parce que
du coup on allait dire du bien de leur
ville c'était une ville jolie fleurie
mignonne etc et c'est sûr que on a on a
pris énormément de retard sur ces années
où on a laissé sans quitter et
s'installer tout cela alors aujourd'hui
là je vous parle des quartiers mais
effectivement au-dessus de ça vous avez
des pays des pays des narcos état dans
le monde qui eux aussi ne vivent que
grâce à cette main bien sûr
qu'on a pris mais c'est pire que ça
quand on lit le livre on a l'impression
que nos frontières sont les passoires
que la drogues circulent que l'argent
est immensément réinvesti dans le petit
commerce honnêtement on est foutu on a
l'impression que l'argent de la drogue
il est là et c'est fini bah lui c'est
pas le plus
dans le Pays Basque c'est maintenant
tous les deux ou trois mois qu'elle est
trafiquants ça coûte tellement rien la
drogue ça ne coûte parce que parce que
ça rapporte ça rapporte ça coûte rien de
produire donc du coup dès qu'ils ont les
flics au cul il balance tout la flotte
et avec les marées à Biarritz Biarritz
tous les mois pratiquement il y a des
opérations les plages sont interdites
parce qu'on trouve des vélos de jouer
les contrôles qui sont mis en place dans
les ports
japonais qui a trouvé 2 kg de cocaïne en
tant que
commissariats pour pouvoir ils ont
toujours un temps d'avance en fait sur
ceux qui sont ceux qui leur court après
toujours bien sûr toujours et donc là on
est en train de renforcer les contrôles
dans les ports notamment au Havre
français ou averses ou à Marseille comme
ça se fait à Rotterdam et à Anvers alors
qu'est-ce qu'ils ont décidé de faire
c'est de de en gros de faire des ballots
avec des balises et des bouées qui
balancent en mer qu'ils encre en mer il
pose ça donc le bateau qui arrive et qui
nous livre ça depuis le Brésil depuis la
République domin je ne sais aussi les
suivis où il pose ça ils disparaît on
attend deux trois jours éventuellement
on surveille avec des drones on regarde
ce qui se passe s'il y a si l'armée si
la Marine a repéré si la police est sur
le coup et si elle l'est pas on va on va
récupérer les ballons avant on va
récupérer des homard maintenant récupère
mais
la cocaïne au gramme vaut plus cher que
l'origine effectivement un coup d'avance
et ils sont sur armés donc sur dangereux
et les go fast les beaux de face les
flag face et on les suit pas tellement
ça peut être dangereux sur l'autoroute
et tout ça mais ce que je veux dire ce
qui est important aussi je fais un petit
peu de social c'est qu'en France on
s'intéresse toujours aux conséquences et
jamais aux causes un môme qui a 14 ans
qui est dans une cité qui a été
déscolarisée qui a que dalle ses parents
peuvent pas l'entretenir et tout ça bah
ils en parlent la garde regarde
entre 11 et 12 ans c'est là qu'on
s'intéresse au business à l'argent
bénéfice j'ai grandi dans une famille où
on était neuf garçons et une fille comme
argent j'avais zéro tout le monde doit
se démerder chacun pour soi et Dieu pour
tous à un moment les grands du quartier
viennent te voir et te demande tu veux
faire beaucoup d'argent j'ai dit oui et
ben très honnêtement
est-ce qu'on aurait pas dit oui non mais
tu vois ce que je veux dire on a 13 ans
on a rien est-ce que c'est mom là on
peut comprendre bah disons que c'est
effectivement ils ont grandi sur ces
territoires ils en sortent très peu ils
connaissent pas tellement le monde
extérieur ce que je rencontre je suis
assez surpris quelquefois je veux dire à
ils habitent à 5 6 7 km de Paris il y a
un diamètre qui sort sur Paris pour 90
ans les pieds à Paris donc ils
grandissent là-dedans et effectivement
le bon soit soit ils sont footballeurs
euh c'est un peu c'est un peu les deux
modèles soit il rentre dans cette
économie de la drogue dans laquelle ils
sont un peu souvent forcés et entraînés
par par les par les grands frères et
Chris il a il avait beau avoir 14 15 ans
il m'a il m'a sorti une phrase
absolument extraordinaire pour son âge
j'ai trouvé il m'a dit la drogue c'est
comme l'électricité ça tourne ça tourne
ça tourne et d'une certaine manière je
trouve l'image magnifique c'est à dire
elle est très juste à bientôt
l'électricité
il vaut mieux pas la stocker il vaut
mieux pas la stocker électricité c'est
compliqué à stocker la drogue c'est
pareil parce que si vous la stockez vous
vous risquez de vous faire démasquer
donc on la stocke pas et ça en
permanence il y a des consommateurs tout
le temps qui viennent mais ce qui n'ont
rien à perdre monsieur c'est ça ce que
les trafiquants parce que les
trafiquants ont peur de la police alors
je pense que là ce qu'on quand on
regarde ce qui se passe à Marseille on
sait on sait que d'un côté l'état
mènerait réellement une drogue entre une
guerre contre la drogue l'État est en
guerre contre la box et officielle tout
le monde le sait tout le monde met les
moyens tous les ministres le disent à
tour de rôle mais les la guerre la plus
importante alors Dieu finalement cette
guerre n’importe peu et je dirais qu'ils
n'ont pas tellement peur de cette guerre
là ce dont ils ont peur ce sont des
guerres qui se livrent entre eux et des
ventes d'étages des ventes d'État qui ne
se livrent entre eux là quand vous
regardez sur une semaine environ 7
réglement de compte à Marseille vous
vous dites et puis avec des réactions
immédiates c'est à dire un règlement de
contagieux vous allez chercher
éventuellement un tuyau à gage qui se
faisait pas avant maintenant ça se fait
aussi en France ça se faisait que en
Amérique du Sud donc vous allez chercher
un tueur à gage vous lui donnez moi le
prix qu'on m'a donné c'est 10000 euros
il va immédiatement et donc il y a des
riposte immédiates sans réfléchir ce
sont des des garçons
mais ce sont des gens qui se qui se
brûlent même et qui savent qu'ils vont
pas aller très loin parce que ça c'est
une manière c'est assez contre-productif
quand on regarde bien quel est l'intérêt
aux États-Unis c'est comme ça aussi aux
États-Unis tu as des mecs pour pourquoi
pour 8000 dollars voilà tu vois beaucoup
moins quel est le aux États-Unis
ils ont ce même problème ou c'est nous
la France qu'avant une police faible non
non le problème est le même problème
c'est vraiment le même partout partout
dans le monde c'est Frédéric c'est
passionnant autant que tu dis mais on
n'est pas là dans un débat ma chérie on
est en train de vraiment de voir le
lycée c'est pour revenir sur ce qu'il a
dit ok
c'est responsables non mais la drogue
est partout exactement
qui n'a plus rien à perdre il faut
s'occuper de lui sinon il va tomber
là-dedans là vous parlez du client et
voilà moi c'est donc ça ça complète et à
mon avis
ou parler du client lui parle voilà
les clients sont comme il dit les grands
frères vont venir le voir du quartier
juste pour écrire ton liste interrogé le
commissaire Serge Castello capacité 6
ans et demi à la tête de la sécurité
publique il a dit selon lui le 93 c'est
un Arco département alors lui il pèse
ces mots hein c'est quand même un grand
flic quand il me dit ça c'est il sait de
XS de quoi il parle et en fait ce qu'il
veut dire c'est que quand dans ce
département effectivement il y a des le
poids des espèces en circulation est tel
que ça modifie l'équilibre normal c'est
voilà l'économie parallèle c'est ça un
Arco état c'est quand l'économie
parallèle supplante l'économie réelle
parce que justement elle brasse plus de
moyens et d'argent et qu'à partir de là
c'est d'une certaine manière elle impose
sa loi parce que celui qui a celui qui a
les masses de billets impose sa loi donc
c'est en ce sens là que me disait ce ce
commissaire me faisait cette réflexion
c'est aussi qu'il y a des affaires de
corruption de plus en plus nombreux
c'est où le faut-il légaliser alors que
ce soit que ce soit la cocaïne tu vois
ce que j'ai dit
[Applaudissements]
merci Géraldine de l'avoir recadré c'est
un véritable métier des exigences
regardez ce que dit Christ le dealer la
ponctualité on te dit viens à midi tu
viens à midi pas à midi une 12h02 ou
12h03 la tenue requise des vêtements de
couleur noire censé rendre moins
repérables possible Daniel tu vas être
difficile du travail
des équipiers assistant obligatoire
celui qui surveille s'il y a la police
c'est ça rémunérer environ 50 euros par
jour pour crier Pupu ou Joe tu es mort
Jo tu es mort quand un policier mais
pied à terre c'est ça voilà c'est dans
chaque quartier chaque quartier a
inventé ces expressions en fait
absolument sur les expressions ça change
aux quatre coins de la fête mais ce qui
est clair c'est qu'il y a une c'est
qu'en fait ils sont assez structurés
l'air de rien ils ont il y a une il y a
une vraie école du crime il y a une
formation il y a une ascension sociale à
l'intérieur du crime c'est vraiment un
monde parallèle qui ressemble et qui
copie le monde qui est le monde
capitaliste en gros mais dans le Saint
Jean d'une certaine manière et en
poussant à bout on va dire tous les
défauts tous les travers du libéralisme
du capitalisme parce que dans le
capitalisme ordinaire si vous avez un
souci avec un voisin vous allez
éventuellement au tribunal là vous n'y
allez pas et c'est tout de suite voilà
les coûts c'est tout de suite voilà
c'est ça qui sortent c'est l'arme qui
sort aujourd'hui c'est malheureusement
c'est plus des 1143 comme autrefois ce
sont des armes de guerre et donc comme
on l'a vu encore récemment les armes de
guerre ça se contrôle beaucoup moins
facilement car on sera 40 c'est ça
exactement je veux dire autant de gens
qui le mat c'était en gros il y avait un
individu à éliminer parce que il fallait
se venger mais on prenait le 11 43 et on
a rosé pas
aujourd'hui c'est c'est un petit peu
plus compliqué donc il y a une certaine
folie beaucoup plus compliqué
la police elle fait elle fait quand même
sur son boulot
parce que voilà c'est à tous les niveaux
c'est compliqué pour le flic de base à
la BAC qui court après le même le même
petit jeune tous les jours et qu'il
revoit le lendemain et qui lui dit nique
ta mère c'est beaucoup aussi compliqué
pour aujourd'hui à vivre que celui qui
est en brigade d'élite et qui cherche et
qui va mettre 6 mois à démonter un
trafic parce qu'il faut accumuler
l'épreuves parce que sinon en justice il
se passe rien et qui pendant six mois se
mord les doigts attend et s'impatiente
parce qu'effectivement pendant ce
temps-là le trafic continue à partir il
y a des horaires chargés c'est ce que
dit Chris à partir du moment où tout est
en place le bicraveur vend il fait du
Midi minuit temps plein des tickets
resto à la pause on lui donne sa gamelle
il peut avoir un Grec qu'il consomme là
où il bosse ou se retrouver chez la
nourrice la maman une dame qui garde le
produit qui lui fera à manger l'argent
ça et partout autour de nous 25 c'est le
gérant qui paye 10 euros le repas pas
plus pas 11 euros c'est inclus dans la
paye c'est ça absolument ils sont pas
forcément généreux même si il croule
sous l'argent c'est c'est une économie
qui a qui a ses règles il faut pas
déborder et puis je vous assure je vois
celui qui a un moment donné soit vient
en retard soit prend une petite barrette
et la ramène chez lui soit ne déclare
pas une vente on risque de lui casser
les mains moi j'ai des dizaines
d'affaires de cas comme ça ça va très
loin et ça va très vite ça commence
effectivement par des violences je veux
dire un peu ou tabou briser les doigts
en plus en plus comme on est dans une
société
en plus comme mon film il filme leur
propre violence il les mettent en scène
pour justement montrer qu'ils sont durs
et violents et pour justement intimider
les autres donc c'est ça crée c'est en
cela pour je reviens la première
question c'est en cela que la drogue
crée du désordre ça elle crée énormément
de violence auto autour d'elle induite
par tous ces enlèvements c'est si vous
payez pas si vous payez pas à la
livraison si vous payez pas vos dettes
vous finissez à la cave dans un premier
temps ensuite on peut vous percer les
genoux et puis dans la troisième temps
on va vous retrouver dans le coffre
d'une voiture cramée donc c'est une
économie qui qui en permanence comme ça
90% des règlements de compte sont en
lien avec le trafic le stupéfiant c'est
ça qu'il faut savoir et ça c'est
vraiment le chiffre le plus important
parce qu'on entend tellement de monde
actuellement c'est vraiment à cause de
ce que je veux dire c'est que la police
judiciaire elle en résoudre des
règlements de compte bien sûr mais le
problème le problème c'est que les
réseaux le il les résolvent plus vite
donc ils vont buter celui qui est donc
après la police arrive c'est toujours en
retard bah forcément
pour faire une enquête criminelle digne
de ce nom il faut énormément de procès
verbaux et de temps et en attendant ben
finalement l'auteur chercher que vous
auriez volonté renvoyer en prison ben il
est mort il est déjà mort